[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hi zusammen hier ist eure Natalie und
hier ist Mirko hallo heute geht es um
einen unfassbar kaputten Typen und um
den Strafvollzug in Deutschland wir
sprechen über Frank Schmökel aus
Brandenburg der Mann der immer wieder
unfassbare Taten begehen konnte und
deshalb geht es auch darum was alles
schief gehen kann wenn man es mit
psychisch gestörten Gewalttätern zu tun
hat dazu hat die Redaktion uns mal ein
paar Punkte zusammengefasst zum Thema
Strafvollzug in Deutschland oberstes
Ziel der Strafjustiz bei uns ist nämlich
die Resozialisierung wer also ein
Verbrechen begangen hat soll also in der
Haft auf die Rückkehr in ein normales
Leben vorbereitet werden für Fälle in
denen die Täter psychisch erkrankt sind
oder unter einer Sucht leiden gibt es
den Maßregelvollzug der soll auch der
Resozialisierung dienen aber die Täter
werden in geschlossenen Psychiatrien
oder entziehungsanstalten untergebracht
wenn man annimmt dass jemand auch nach
der eigentlich üblichen Freiheit Strafe
noch gefährlich bleibt kann ein Gericht
versicherungsverwahrung anordnen das
heißt der Straftäter bleibt auch nach
der Haft weggesperrt das muss laut
Gesetz eine Einrichtung sein die eine
psychische Betreuung anbietet denn
selbst in der Sicherungsverwahrung
bleibt das Ziel theoretisch die Rückkehr
in die Gesellschaft nur um es mal
einzuordnen pro Jahr sitzen in
Deutschland zwischen 50 und 60.000
Menschen im Strafvollzug darunter etwa
92% Männer und 8% Frauen 16 Prozent von
den rund 50.000 sind im offenen Vollzug
der Rest im Gefängnis und und ein
Zehntel der Straftäter sitzen im
Maßregelvollzug wenn alles gut geht
schützt uns die Justiz vor gefährlichen
Tätern und hilft Verbrechern von der
schiefen Bahn wieder in ein normales
Leben zu kommen das geht auch für viele
allerdings nicht für Frank Schmökel
[Musik]
Schmökel wird am 19 August 1962 in
Strausberg in Brandenburg geboren der
Polizistensohn ist also ein Kind der DDR
die Eltern lassen sich scheiden als
Frank neun Jahre alt ist nach
laubeneinbrüchen und Brandstiftungen
verbüßte eine Jugendstrafe danach wird
er von den Behörden zur Sozialarbeiter
von dem Hof in Mecklenburg geschickt und
arbeitet als Melker Schmökel hat
offenbar zwei Gesichter er macht sich
bei den anderen auf dem Hof beliebt
backt leckeren Kuchen und geht ein sehr
kollegial aber schon bald zeigt er seine
dunklen Seiten er vergeht sich an
Kälbern dann fällt er über ein
14-jähriges Mädchen in der Nachbarschaft
her die Tochter des örtlichen Kulturhaus
Leiters Beatrix war Schmökel wohl
aufgefallen als sie ihrem Vater beim
Zaun sitzen half
als schmücke des Mädchen allein zu Hause
weint steigt er übers Dachfenster ein
doch in Beatrix Zimmer ist auch noch
deren Freundin Schmökel ist perplex das
Mädchen steht sich aus dem Haus während
er mit einem Messer in der Hand nach ihr
sucht später sitzt er da und stammelt
dass es ihm leid tut von jetzt an wird
es nie wieder ein normales Leben geben
für Frank Schmökel es wird alles nur
schlimmer 1988 wird er also zum ersten
Mal wegen einer Gewalt hat zu anderthalb
Jahren Freiheitsstrafe vorurteilt
nachdem er kurze Zeit geflohen war komm
weitere 10 Monate dazu aber schon 1989
kommt Schmökel im Rahmen einer Teil
eines die frei
1990 kehrt er in seinen Geburtsort
Strausberg zurück arbeitet auf dem Bauch
verdient gutes Geld aber noch im selben
Jahr fällt er wieder über ein Mädchen
her weitere Vergewaltigungen Folgen
Schmökel kriegt fünfeinhalb Jahre und
schon jetzt ordnet das Landgericht
Antwort oder die Unterbringung im
Maßregelvollzug der brandenburgischen
Landesklinik an jetzt ist Schmökel mit
Verlaub da wo er hingehört aber der Mann
ist nicht nur ein übler Sexualstraftäter
ihm gelingt immer wieder die Flucht
Frank Schmökel aus Strausberg in
Brandenburg ist jetzt zu dem erwachsenen
Straftäter geworden wie in die
Öffentlichkeit kennen und fürchten lernt
er hat eine eher durchschnittliche
Statur einen vergleichsweise schmalen
Kopf meist kurze Haare dunkle
eindringliche Augen und eine etwas
breitere Nase 1994 entkommt Schmökel
während eines Freigangs er vergewaltigt
den quizero eine Elfjährige und versucht
sie umzubringen wegen sexuellen
Missbrauchs und versuchten Mordes wird
er daraufhin zu 14 Jahren
Freiheitsstrafe erneut im
Maßregelvollzug verurteilt so gesehen
tun die Richter jeweils was sie können
aber was hilft das wenn im Justizvollzug
dann doch geschlampt wird wenn das ganze
hier einen ausgedachte Drehbuch wäre
würden die Kritiker zu recht sagen jetzt
übertreibt er aber hört man wie es
weitergeht 16 november 1995
Schmökel gelingt die Flucht aus der
Klinik bereits am nächsten Tag fast in
die Polizei
24 Juli 1996 Schmökel entweicht bei
einem begleiteten Freigang drei Tage
später bringen in die Polizeibeamten
zurück
19 februar 1997 gemeinsam mit anderen
Häftlingen sägt Schmökel ein
Fenstergitter auf und entkommt erneut er
stellt sich am 27 februar am 1 märz wird
er in den Maßregelvollzug in Neuruppin
verlegt
16 September 1997 auch in Neuruppin
glüht Schmökel die Flucht aus dem
Fenster am folgenden Tag wird er
gestellt man könnte meinen spätestens
jetzt würde die justizkäppchen was hier
los ist und diesen Mann einfach nie
wieder in die Nähe eines Fenster sondern
eine Tür lassen jeden Ausgang oder jeden
Freigang ja gar Bewährung überhaupt
streichen das überhaupt gar nicht erst
in Erwägung ziehen schmökels
Fluchtversuche halten auch die
Öffentlichkeiten Atem Bild zeigte märz
1997 ein Foto von Schmökel in einem
Polizeiauto die Überschrift lautet Sex
Gangster verhaftet er lebte vom Müll im
Artikel heißt es Zivil fahrender hatten
ihn in die Enge getrieben sie um seinen
Unterschlupf die Hütte eines
kinderferienheims Schmökel lebte hier
ohne Schuhe ohne Socken ohne Jacke er
suchte sich Essen von einer Müllhalde
vom hungergeschwächt gab er jetzt auf er
ging in eine Telefonzelle und rief die
Polizei an hallo ich bin's der Schmökel
holt mich ab die Beamten nahm ihn fest
LKA-Sprecher Peter sahlender wir sind
froh dass er von der Straße ist nach
diesem Durcheinander noch mal in Ruhe
wir sind jetzt im Herbst 1997 Frank
Schmökel ist zurück im Maßregelvollzug
im brandenburgischen Neuruppin und
tatsächlich hat die Öffentlichkeit nun
erstmal Ruhe das nächste Unheil kündigt
sich im April 2000 an Schmökel erhält
lockerungsstufe 4 das beinhaltet die
Möglichkeit von Freigängern mal ganz
ehrlich das kann doch echt nicht wahr
sein man erlebt viel verrücktes Zeug mit
all diesen kriminalen Fällen aber das
hier ist echt wirklich crazy
Liebe Nathalie dann brauchst Du jetzt
aber wirklich gute Nerven am 25 oktober
2000 erhält Frank Schmökel Ausgang er
darf seine Mutter Marianne in Strausberg
im Kreis Märkisch-Oderland besuchen er
wird von den Pflegern der
psychiatrischen Anstalt sowie einem
Sozialpädagogen begleitet beim Kuchen
essen im Wohnzimmer der Mutter kommt es
zum Streit Schmökel schnappt sich das
Messer mit dem der Kuchen geschnitten
wurde und sticht auf seine Mutter ein
sie wird schwer verletzt die Pfleger
gehen dazwischen einer von ihnen wird
lebensgefährlich verletzt und Schmökel
tut was er am besten kann er flieht und
dieses Mal ruft er nirgends an und sagt
ich bin's der Schmökel holt mich hier ab
diesmal bleibt er auf der Flucht aber
wie sich zeigt dann fährt er sich nicht
besonders weit von seiner Geburt statt
Strausberg eine Woche später ermordet
Schmökel am Straussee den 60 Jahre alten
Berliner Rentner Johannes B auf dessen
Wohngrundstück
er will Bees Auto haben und der ruft
danach tatsächlich einen Psychiater an
und gesteht diese Tat aber er stellt
sich nicht erst am 7 November nach 13
Tagen auf der Flucht nach der größten
Fahndungsaktionen Ostdeutschland wird
der gesuchte Schwerverbrecher in der
Nähe von Bautzen festgenommen er leidet
einen Bauchschuss und wird unter
schärfster Bewachung nur operiert
2002 der Prozess vor dem Landgericht
Neuruppin das Urteil lebenslange Haft
mit anschließender Sicherungsverwahrung
Schmökel wird wieder mal in den
Maßregelvollzug für psychisch kranke
Straftäter gesteckt dieser Prozess hat
das echt in sich denn Schmökel zeigt
dass er eben nicht nur ein stumpfer
Gewalttäter und Sexverbrecher ist
sondern durch das schlau argumentieren
kann im Verfahren stellte sich nämlich
als Opfer da Schmökel behauptet von
seiner Mutter missbraucht worden zu sein
deshalb sei er beim Kaffee Besucher auch
so ausgerastet außerdem kritisiert
Schmökel den Maßregelvollzug und
behauptet die Psychiater hätten ihn
letztendlich noch kranker gemacht als
zuvor ja aber der Richter nimmt möglich
die Piraten nicht ab im Prozess wird
aber auch deutlich wie schlampig im
Vollzug mit gefährlichen Tätern wie
schmückel umgegangen wurde einer der
Pfleger der beim Ausraster dabei war
sagt im Verfahren als Zeuge aus ich
hatte erst fünf Tage vor diesem Einsatz
bei schmuckes Mutter als Pfleger in
Neuruppin angefangen
ich habe dafür gar keine Ausbildung
Schmökel war der erste Patient den ich
auf Ausgang begleitet habe ich habe
gehört dass erst einen Monat davor ein
anderer Insasse mit Hilfe eines Messers
ausgebrochen war aus Neuruppin Schmökel
geht gegen das Urteil in Revision aber
vergebens der Beschluss wird am 12
november 2003 rechtskräftig und zum
Glück gibt es auch endlich Folgen für
den katastrophalen Maßregelvollzug in
Brandenburg schon nach schmückes letzter
Flucht im Jahr 2000 tritt Brandenburg
sozialstaatssekretär Herwig Schirmer
zurück der SPD-Politiker hatte die
Fachaufsicht über die Nervenklinik
Neuruppin und später untersuchte eine
Kommission die Zustände im
psychiatrischen Vollzug des Landes
systematisch und das Ergebnis ist
natürlich wenig überraschend die
Einrichtungen sind wieder baulich noch
von der Qualifikation des Personals Herr
tauglich das gesamte System in
Brandenburg muss buchstäblich umgebaut
werden so Natalie ich auf den Puls hat
sich langsam wieder beruhigt ja aber ich
muss nicht gestehen nur langsam aber
immerhin wurden ja auch schlussendlich
Konsequenzen gezogen und damit können
wir jetzt den vorläufig letzten Akt in
diesem schrecklichen Stück erzählen und
dafür kehren wir an den Anfang dieses
Podcasts zurück wie wir erklärt hatten
schickt man psychisch kranke Straftäter
in den Maßregeln Vollzug damit sie
behandelt werden und vielleicht
irgendwann mal ins normale Leben
zurückkehren können aber Frank Schmökel
ist einer der wenigen Fälle bei denen es
am Ende anders herum läuft 2017 erklären
die Experten den Patienten Frank
Schmökel für nicht therapierbar wegen
seiner dissozialen und narzisstischen
Persönlichkeitsstörung wurde er nach
seine Verbrechen immer zuerst den
Kliniken gesteckt wo er behandelt werden
sollte aber nach 23 Jahren ist damit
endgültig Schloss das heißt schmücke
fliegt im Frühjahr 2017 vom Gelände der
Klinik in Neuruppin und muss in die
Moderne JVA in Guben dort gibt es für
Kinder Ständer und Mörder eigens einen
Sicherheitstrakt und wenn ich einen
bescheidenen Wunsch äußern darf das soll
er für immer bleiben und von mir aus
auch verrotten ja und das ist für die
Sicherheit der Gesellschaft auf jeden
Fall die beste Entscheidung
[Musik]
Aufnahme und schnitt Antonia Heyer den
Fall haben wir mit Artikeln aus Bild und
BILD am SONNTAG erzählt wir haben eine
beeindruckende gerichtsreportage der
damaligen spiegelgerichtsreporterin
Gisela Friedrichsen gelesen und berichte
aus der märkischen allgemeinen das
Skript für heute hat Stefan Netze Bank
geschrieben und wenn ihr Interesse an
den Statistiken der Justiz bekommen habt
findet ihr einen Link in den Show Notes
bis bald eure Natalie und euer Mirko